bring my nipples on vacation with me I  do I bring them they're not staying at  home and and sometimes and listen by the  way it's the south of France where we  were oh nothing but you know that's  where you let that's isn't that the land  of being topless I mean why you know  equal for everybody let's go I don't  know because I went to Italy with my two  daughters and got paparazzied in my  bathing suit and I've never felt more  vulnerable I looked like a sheep that  had just been walled in five degree  weather I mean when I found out that  there was pictures on The Daily Mail of  me in a bathing suit with my cottage  cheese and my two kids I I literally  think organs fell out of my body I was  like  did they catch me eating too like mid  bite looking like I was deep throating a  burger like at the same time was I  picking my nose like what else can we  just show